as day breaks over the Swiss Alps some
are already hard at work
high above mountain Patrol are the
guardians of the slopes keeping them
safe takes drastic measures handle with
care that's dynamo seconds time to go on
the safety place for hard-to-reach areas
the mountain patrol use something a
little more direct the use of more into
Swiss Army but they we use it's perfect
for the all allowances are works very
well last night's heavy snowfall means
there's work to be done
controlled avalanches are vital to
keeping the slopes safe you see that as
if it's almost ice one week ago we had
rain and that's always really bad that's
when we have t snow and the beginning on
the winter time then we have a problem
actually the whole winter time and it
doesn't take much to trigger a slide you
always need a a weak layer depends how
much noise above this weak layer the
avalanche
good one but it also helps if you know
what you're looking for it's like an
open book you just have to read over
there there is there are a lot of cracks
already here we try to do it and
artificial for the slopes out of reach
they call on the Swiss Army
released I think that's not so far so
good the ridge is safe what's a day